foreign
[Music]
into the burning building
but until we feel that heat
we can never know
you do
[Music]
we chose to die instead of giving up
your colleagues
[Music]
I'm gonna test you past
not everybody does
Welcome to the afterlife
[Music]
to do what I do
I need some idea of the threat we face
three
nuclear Holocaust no
something washed
all I have for you is a word
tell it
it'll open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
I have to start looking at the world in
a new way
[Music]
feel it
it'll happen here
hasn't happened yet
[Music]
the state department is pulling an agent
that specializes in responding to
escalating cartel activity
[Music]
this is not my department
you want to be a part of this
do we get an opportunity of the man
responsible for today men who are really
responsible for today
and what is before we're going to El
Paso right
you're not American
what do you work for now well I go where
I'm set
[Music]
every day across that border people are
killed with his Blessing
to find no one would be like discovering
a vaccine
American years but in the end you will
understand spot our vehicle left lane
I'm not a soldier this is not what I do
Juarez is what happens when they dig in
this is it
gotta be careful on these people CIA is
not supposed to work this side of the
fact
[Music]
excuse me
providing a measure of order that we
could control
that would be a major mistake
[Music]
good
I chose this life
and someday
it's going to get me killed
but not today
[Music]
Lorraine Broughton it's an expert in
intelligence collection
agent gascoigne was killed last night
[Music]
did you know him enough to say hello
he had an atomic bomb of information
find out who's hunting our operators and
trust no one
doesn't feel
David the person it's your content
welcome to Berlin I'm David don't shoot
I've got your shoe
[Music]
that was me from the moment my feet
touched the ground
it's never part of the plan it was part
of mine I've lost the target
what do you know about this woman who's
been following me he looked like you
need saving
[Applause]
so you made contact with the French
operator obviously
[Music]
the clock is ticking and everyone you
get close to ends up dead
someone set me up someone from the
inside
now there's only ends one way
a bullet ready
[Music]
oh my God I think I love you that's too
bad
[Music]
all right
Our Lives
are the sum of our choices
[Music]
and we cannot escape the past
Ethan this mission of yours
is gonna cost you
dearly
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing war is coming
it's been a long time
you've no idea the power I represents
it knows your story and How It Ends
listen to me the world's coming after
you
his fate is written
shall we write yours too if anything
happens to them there's no place that I
won't go to kill you that is written
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I can't accept that
[Music]
it's gone
you better know what's at stake here
there isn't much Road left to take the
bloody shot
all right
what do you say about a man like that
three months ago you lost the drive
containing the identity of every agent
embedded in Terrorist organizations
across the globe
007 reporting for Duty where the hell
have you been enjoying death
I only have one question why not stay
dead there's no shame in saying you've
lost a step
they weren't targeting her they wanted
her to see it welcome to the new MI6
I'm a quartermaster you must be joking
both the PPKs nine millimeter short it's
been coded to deal palm print so only
you can fire it best of a random killing
machine more of a personal statement
q707
I want to meet your employer how much do
you know about fear well there is not
like this
[Music]
just look at you chasing spies England
and my six
she send you after me know when you're
not ready know when you would likely die
mommy was very bad
the two survivors this is what she made
us everybody needs a hobby so what's
yours
Resurrection
[Music]
foreign
intelligence needs a job to be done
there's a German law will let
it our unit was set up to develop
resources we're not policemen we're
spies
our sources don't come to us
good to see you we find them
when they're ours we direct them at
bigger targets
it takes our minnow to catch a barracuda
a barracuda to catch a shark we're
moving
you can't do this I'm a lawyer oh yeah a
social worker for terrorists you've
crossed the line you're on their side
now
I'm frightened not just bi can't do this
anymore you're my ears are my eyes I
need you
we have a job to do you're going to help
me do it
Martha Sullivan U.S embassy Berlin
lose money through a network of Muslim
Charities and every time he does some of
it goes missing he's moving
the pink company he's got a lot of
friends here in Berlin what's your back
the man's tolerant engaged with the west
but every good man has a little bit of
bad doesn't he and in abdullah's case
that little bit just might kill you we
have three hours to apprehend Abdullah
make him ours
hello
if this kid lets off a bomb it's in your
hands
I'm not doing this for you most of us
don't get to choose I gave you Isa Isa
gives you Abdullah what's next
maybe you could Define for us what the
long-term objective would be
make the world a safer place
isn't that enough
[Music]
can I be honest with you
I am bad news
I'm not your friend
I'm not gonna help you
[Music]
I'm gonna break you
any questions
Maya this is Joseph Bradley our station
Chief nice to meet you thank you sir
you don't think she's a little young for
the hard stuff
Washington says she's a killer
[Music]
I want to make something clear we're
spending billions of dollars
we're still no closer to defeating our
enemy
20 detainees recognize that photo no
birth certificate no cell phone your
guy's a ghost
you really believe this story
Osama bin Laden yeah what convinced you
her confidence
this is a professional attempt to avoid
detection
real tradecraft
of all people
[Music]
you never get off
there's a 60 probability he's there
[Music]
I'd say it's a soft 60 sir
well it's 100
a certainty freaks you guys out but it's
a hundred
you will never find him
he is one of the Disappeared ones
who was I they gave you so many
identities achiever Lee Kane born you
were one of the first ones in the
program
we have a situation porn showed up on
our surveillance in southern Europe tour
in Italy London
he's retracing his steps looking for
something we need to know what it is
someone made me what I am
and I'm gonna find him who's voting he
trained you things with you from the
beginning he knows who you are We're Not
Gonna Let You Go they need to bring you
home in a body bag
he's within 1 000 yards of this building
he's communicating
going out there get the vehicles We're
Going Mobile follow Landy she leads us
to Jason Bourne you need to find him we
need to take him out
of awesome this is Jason Bourne I was
wondering when you were going to make
this call perhaps we can arrange a meet
where are you now I'm sitting in my
office
I doubt that why would you doubt that if
you were in your office right now we'd
be having this conversation face to face
everyone back to the building don't tell
me he's gone
[Applause]
he has our entire Playbook names dates
ghost sights every Dirty Little Secret
we have
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
very careful
I remember
I remember everything
[Music]
actions of Iran have shocked the
Civilized world
everything all right Embassy has been
seized and more than 60 American
citizens
to be held as hostages if we're going to
go then we need to go now
[Music]
foreign
six of the hostages went on a back exit
where are they the Canadian ambassador's
house we've got revolutionary guards
going door to door
these people die they die badly White
House who wants the six of them out what
we like for this are bicycles deliver
the six bikes provide them with maps or
you could just send in training wheels
and meet them at the border with
Gatorade
It's Gonna Take a Miracle to get them
out
funny man what are we watching I got an
idea they're a Canadian film crew for a
science fiction movie I fly into Tehran
we all fly out together as a film crew I
need you to help me make a fake movie so
you want to come to Hollywood and act
like a big shot without actually doing
anything yeah it'll fit right in
script Argo science fantasy Adventure
RuneScape Mars desert we need an exotic
location to shoot you need
if I'm doing a fake movie it's going to
be a fake hit
we have a better bad idea than this this
is the best bad idea we have sir by far
you have 72 hours to get them out
they're getting a visitor you've gotten
people out this way before no
you're asking us to trust you with our
lives this is what I do and I've never
left anyone behind
I know who they are and they know
they're hiding out it's over Tony
they stay here they will be taken
probably not alive
[Applause]
[Music]
we're responsible for these people
I'm responsible
[Music]
you really believe your little story is
going to make a difference when there's
a gun to our heads I think my little
story is the only thing between you and
a gun to your head
[Music]
you know you can tell when you're the
world's greatest spy long starting
[Music]
Lance Sterling
everyone knows the name
[Music]
don't take the loss so hard I mean you
got to meet Land Sterling
[Music]
is too much
it's probably the right amount but still
go back to work
[Music]
I've been working on this thing at home
it is Gonna Change spying forever it's
called biodynamic concealment imagine if
I can make you wait for it drum roll
please disappear
[Music]
here disappear
why are you saying it like that for a
fact
that next Generation concealment pack
you wouldn't happen to have it on hand
would you I do happen to have it in hand
show it to me sure
um well can I offer you a drink I got
water drinkable meal replacement we had
a drink diet stuff has a weird
aftertaste what's the tech
um well you
it worked
[Music]
subject appears disoriented Foster what
did you do hey Lance look at me look at
you I can't not look at you Walter I can
see my butt and your face at the same
time baby
pigeons are everywhere and nobody
notices them wow girl it's the most
perfect form of spy could take you
better unbird me right now that's it I'm
not playing with you I'm burnt I'm
raising my voice I probably shouldn't be
raising my voice at you I need you to
unburn me Walter technically you burn it
yourself
it's freezing why are we walking the car
keys
huge IQ great performance in the Marines
but you gave up
I've never had a job who are you your
father saved my life this is your fair
guy boys
I've had a rather emotional day so
whatever your beef with eggsy is and I'm
sure it's well founded I'd appreciate it
if you could just leave us in peace you
should get out of the way Granddaddy
look at her
make it
man
you know what that means
then let me teach you a list
are we going to stand around here all
day or are we going to fight
foreign
[Music]
intelligence agency operating at the
highest level of discretion if you're
prepared to adapt you can transform into
a spy interesting oh yes if you are
about to embark on the most dangerous
job interview in the world we're here to
test you to a limit to enhance your
skills
trained for the evil out there
[Music]
you have to take
to take to everyone who said I never
make it felt sorry for the boy did you
he's as much Kingsman material as any of
them more so I got a dinner date with
greatness mankind is the virus and I'm
the Cure sounds like a lot of people are
going to die
I look like I give them
you can't always
[Music]
son of a
Congressman no no no you get to come
with Charlie can we uh get you a drink
it's 10 o'clock in the morning fair
enough I guess
[Music]
I'm Charlie Wilson I represent the Texas
I'm standing on the border between
Pakistan and Afghanistan Afghans are now
ready to fight a war against the Soviets
if they get weapons they say they will
win
this is sixth wealthiest woman in Texas
Joanne I have been passionately involved
with the cause of the Afghan since the
day of the Communists marched in why is
Congress saying one thing and doing
nothing Well tradition mostly you sit at
the intersection of the state department
the Pentagon and the CIA the three
agencies you would need to conduct a
covert War yeah
[Music]
I want the CIA in my office at 10. what
is U.S strategy in Afghanistan no
strictly speaking we don't have one but
we're working hard on that lose weight
me and three other guys
I need airplanes Guns and Money a sudden
influx of modern Weaponry would draw
attention draw attention this is a cold
war everybody knows about it there must
be some kind of
[Music]
need to be unprofessional friend of
mine's belly dancer while she's dancing
for the defense minister we'll be
talking to us Deputy oh my God ah she's
supposed to be good
[Music]
and it's going to get done quiet you
have authority to do this none
whatsoever
[Music]
how is it possible that this Congressman
of no particular importance is doing
this by himself
[Music]
this will be the day that I die what is
this rank relative to other covert Wars
there's never been anything else
let me get you a drink oh I love any
kind of whiskey we don't have alcohol in
the presidential residence but a lot of
people make that mistake
no
[Music]
you've been selected for a mission which
you are not to discuss with anyone
outside of this room
we are engaged in a war with the Soviet
Union
this word is not for the moment to
involve men in arms it involves
information
something important has come up we've
got a Soviet spies
but there's a wrinkle
they've got a spy pilot
or the head full of classified
information
the Russians want their man back before
he cracks we want you to negotiate the
swamp I'm an insurance lawyer
sure I want to pick that up
are you good at what you do this will be
a first for the both of us
you should be careful
I'm talking to you about the security of
your country why aren't we hanging here
you're asking me to violate the
constitution do you know how people will
look at us the family of a man trying to
free a traitor everyone deserves a
defense every person matters
[Music]
where do they want this negotiation in
East Berlin if things go south you can't
rely on any help just tell me that
you're not going to be in any danger I
don't even care if it's the truth give
me something to hold on to
we need to have the conversation our
governments can't people in my country
consider this an act of War you can call
it what you want let's be clear nobody
is safe
we're in a battle for civilization the
Constitution that's what makes us
Americans shouldn't we show our enemy
Who We Are
things have started to fall apart is
this your position or your government is
there any outcome here where I'm not
either detained or shot
to worry about you
what's the move when you don't know what
the game is the next mistake our
country's make
the last one
[Music]
there is a mole right at the top of
British intelligence
he's been there for years
for 25 years we've been the only thing
standing between Moscow and the Third
World War
[Music]
I'm retired you're outside the family
you're well pleased to look into this
for us now I'll do my utmost
I know that it is one of these men all I
want from you is one code name tinker
Soldier
[Music]
bye
I need you to do something I'm going to
have to send you up into the lion's den
it's called what the hell are you doing
up here I can't mention me
I know who you are I have something to
trade something big
she told me a secret the mother of all
secrets she had information concerning a
double agent you'll have to assume
they're watching you
things aren't always what they've seen
it becomes so ugly
I'm not so very different
looking for the weaknesses in one
another
[Music]
thank you
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
you said it was clear I said the front
was clear
front front back right wrong anyway
shall we I have another job for you so
what we got Greg Simmons the billionaire
arms dealer oh a lot very serious faces
up here in there you can't catch this
fish with conventional lures I'm sorry
the lower being Danny Francesco
the movie star Greg Simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's the guy very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you I'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law I actually love my
sister-in-law
you made that quite evident when Marine
they're all the killers
you're an actor Act
with someone pinch me please is that
Danny Francesca what's next for you I'm
playing a mysterious self-made
billionaire he just described me shadow
me do whatever I do whatever I do do
however Craig was buying from I was
amongst you last night
I can get inside of them
I hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
what happens you recognized your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name covers blown
what do I do the movie star's gonna melt
did you stopped any Francesca
worry about that
what are you gonna do with that I'm
gonna shoot at them Danny
oh
so you weren't seen by anyone yes that's
a yes to one scene by anyone yes or yes
you were seen by someone yes
[Music]
this wall we're not winning it
if you speak a word of what I'm about to
show you you will be executed for high
treason
beautiful
greatest encryption device in history
and the Germans use it for all
Communications everyone thinks Enigma is
unbreakable let me try anyone know for
sure Mr Turing do you know how many died
because of it
three
while we've been having this
conversation
securing we used to work together then
I'm afraid these men would only slam me
down popular at school way
short on staff we get more stuff then
you have six minutes to complete the
task it's not even possible no
5 minutes and 34 seconds you said to do
it in under six what is it that we're
really doing we're going to break an
unbreakable Nazi code and win the war oh
you know to pull off this irascible
genius routine one actually has to be a
genius
I'm designing a machine that will allow
us to break every message every day
instantly
you're going to need all the help you
can get and they are not going to help
you if they do not like you have you
decrypted a single German message you
will never understand the importance of
what I am creating here our patience has
expired no
if you fire Helen well then you'll have
to fire me me too and me you better
bloody work
and you do not have to do this alone
what are you doing what's going on Navy
thinks one of us is a Soviet spy you've
got more secrets than the best of them
what if I don't fanciful in that way
can't tell anyone no it's illegal
[Applause]
[Music]
people who no one imagines anything old
do the thing
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the audience
[Music]
foreign
thank you
and then I got this job
[Music]
it's family
[Applause]
but nothing lasts forever
I heard you had to leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do I've lived a
lot of lives but I'm done running from
my past
and now you're out there I know you know
I'm out here
so we're going to talk like grown-ups
is that what we are
it's good to see you too sis
what brings you home
we have unfinished business
we have to go back to where it all
started
lucky us
one thing's for sure it's gonna be a
hell of a reunion
thank you
stupid
ly
together again
you got that
[Music]
my name is Bob Wilton I'm a journalist
I've been investigating a story about a
classified government program
so what you're saying is that you
were a psychic spy a Jedi Warrior
I'd heard that the US government was
training psychic soldiers and that Lynn
Cassidy was the best of the best I've
been reactivated I'm on a mission I
could come Lynn's story was unbelievable
crazy and completely true you have to
dream a new America that no longer has
an exploitative view of everyone
you will be a psychic weapon feel it yes
you must create Warrior monks who can
pass through walls
and see into the future congratulations
Scotty sorry it doesn't work out between
you two
what are you doing Cloud versus keeps me
in shape
geez you had like the whole desert to
drive inland
please please
thank you for uh for picking us up
[Music]
how are we going to stop them they've
got guns we're Jedi we don't fight with
guns we fight with our mind
holy
[Music]
[Applause]
I went looking for a story and my friend
Lynn brought me an adventure it's okay
we're Americans we're here to help you
I think I just ran them over oh crap
[Music]
Lieutenant Colonel Django used funds
from the Project's black budget to
procure prostitutes that's a lie and to
get drugs for himself and his men
well the hooker thing is definitely
alive
[Music]